so they're two Secret Service agents I
guess is the right term maybe and to a
lay person to a civilian I think two
more complicated but maybe two actually
provides more surface area SL
opportunity but when you say you went
into their space could you paint a more
detailed picture of how you ended up
taking items from two very well trained
people who have a lot of situational
awareness who know what you do sure you
used a great word there you said surface
area and surface area they have a lot to
protect on themselves both where they
keep their firearms their credentials
the keys uh the itinerary all these
things so they just treat it as a whole
but it's got all these little parts and
I like to think of attention as like a
limited resource it's really useful to
think of kind of the economics of
attention if they spend their attention
one place versus another how do you
toggle that and it's not traditionally
like look here and not there you're
curating their attention so in that
there's ways to approach it and it's
usually contextual it changes from
person to person and when I approached
them I hadn't had an experience with
anyone like that before and the context
was different they knew who I was
specifically when I walked up there's a
nickname for me in the show they called
me klepto they say it's not happening
was I think the first thing I heard from
them and I said no it shouldn't at all I
said yet I think is the word you're
looking for
right so I kind of push at that
boundaries of their confidence level
because I was coming in pretty confident
and one them step back as I approached
and there's a way that I approach that
gains access to someone's space if you
think of
someone's personal space as a bubble the
appropriate reception of how you get
into their awareness of their space it's
kind of shaped like an egg and it's
larger up front it's narrow on the sides
and it's shallow on the back and you can
break eye contact with someone to sneak
underneath that as you move through I
can show you more of that later but
as you gain access there's a way of
approaching from the side that can often
help so when I started to SLE up next to
one of the gentlemen to show him
something he stepped back and they have
a term for it called maintaining
occupied space and it also indicated to
me with slight
brush that in my world I have to know a
lot of be able to determine what's
inside people's pockets and the printing
of a jacket what it means what's my
being able to make pretty good estimates
of what a good Target is inside of the
outline of a pocket so as soon as he
stepped back on the left it indicated to
me that he might have a firearm on that
side versus on his right side so it was
probably underneath in a holster
underneath his jacket M so I just
acknowledged that I put that on the
surface I said you're very well trained
I said it's going to be much harder to
do anything with you I said you've been
doing this for a while and he says yes
I've been doing this for a while and I
said okay so I'm going have to do it to
you sir and so I leaned into the next
guy and the next guy's like that's not
happening and he was very serious but
now as I'm facing him and this other
gentleman is here
he doesn't realize that he's giving me
access from the side the first guy yeah
the first guy he thinks he's off the
clock he thinks he's off the clock and
that's one of the things by setting that
expectation he thinks he's done and the
play has moved on but now I reach
underneath my Army I steal from inside
his jacket and I steal what I found to
be his credentials it was wallet
passport shaped and I steal his glasses
from his outside pocket and I steal a
couple of things and as I was talking to
the other guys as you're doing that does
the other guy notice no he does does
notice and he can't see cuz he's
watching my hands and they're trained to
watch hands but there's all these pause
points I learned over the years from
different thieves and other ones of
holding out places and if I steal
something you're not going to get to see
it go in and out of my pocket or
anything it's going to go somewhere else
so I can put it on them in a more
accessible spot or I can put it on me at
another place so I did some of that but
at the end of that with the two guys I
said you know I didn't get anything said
for this I don't really know what it is
and I pulled out this paper that was
kind of trifold folded and as I'm
opening up I I see what it is it's now
the itinerary where they're taking
Carter to and I said I can't really read
it with these glasses on he realizes
that I'm wearing his glasses that were
in his pocket and he goes hey he takes
my glasses and he looks at the paper and
he says Hey and he snatches it away I
said you know I really don't think you
should read that without the proper ID
and then he real reach in pocket and he
realizes he doesn't have the credentials
and the other guy's laughing very hard
at him I'm sure and he said I'm not
going to be the only one o dad's not
going to be happy with that when he
finds out and so they said he says
you're going to do this to the other
guys so he got on his mic and he starts
telling me to go to other teams so I now
have an advocate and in to approach the
other teams because this guy's sending
me because he didn't want to be the only
one but that's kind of why I just
mentioned about the Jazz I mean I didn't
know I've never stolen with somebody
with presidential itinerary and
credentials and glasses in that combo
before but I have to kind of add Li with
what I find and how I give it back and
it is a unique thing that he knows is
the only time I've done that is with him
until I did it to the other
guys